thanks to endo Chino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
justice Brett Cavanaugh's first term a
Supreme Court justice has come to a
close and it was a big one for the
Supreme Court so recap
Justice Anthony Kennedy retired in 2018
leaving a very important vacancy with
the court Kennedy had been the courts
swing vote lawyers often tailored their
arguments specifically to Kennedy since
he was capable of siding with the courts
liberal wing or the courts conservatives
depending on the specific issue there
was wild speculation as to whether the
court would start making a dramatic
shift now that it has a solid quote
conservative majority and I'll note
parenthetically that the political
alignments of conservative and liberal
don't really hold up when you're talking
about Supreme Court justices but that's
probably a topic for another video on
first blush it looks like Chief Justice
Roberts may be taking up the mantle of
the High Court centrist and deciding
vote this term the Supreme Court has
handed down some big decisions on
partisan gerrymandering the senses
profane trademarks and more now that the
Supreme Court's 2019 term has ended
let's take a look at the most
consequential decisions
[Music]
heyget legal eagles welcome back to real
law review where today we're going to do
a roundup of what I consider the Supreme
Court's most consequential 2019
decisions so let's dig right in the
first is the fuck'd trademark which I am
allowed to say on this channel because
it spelled f UCT not spelled any other
way so it's you know not a swear word so
starting with the fuck'd trademark case
which invalidated a federal law that
prohibited quote immoral or scandalous
trademarks whatever that means which of
course is kind of the point of this
particular Supreme Court case for years
the US Patent and Trademark Office or
USPTO has limited trademark protections
for things it deemed vulgar offensive or
scandalous but in a victory for free
speech the Supreme Court held that the
street clothing called [ __ ] F UCT was
entitled to federal trademark protection
that issue was the trademark act of 1905
which prohibits the registration of
immoral and scandalous trademarks
however under the First Amendment you
can see where this is probably going the
government can't penalize a person's
speech because it disagrees with a
viewpoint being expressed here the
viewpoint being swear words I guess the
Supreme Court held that it's impossible
for the USPTO to decide what it
considered scandalous or immoral without
resorting to viewpoint discrimination
there is no coherent sense of these
terms therefore the USPTO simply applies
its own sense of what is right and wrong
and scandalous and what's not scandalous
which has some real First Amendment
problems the 1905 law has led to some
bizarre decisions by the USPTO for
example the government granted a
trademark for the company that using the
word for cooked
fcuk but denied it for [ __ ] fu CT even
though both simply play on the word
which we have to bleep because that one
is spelled F uck because YouTube is more
arbitrary and capricious than the USPTO
at this point anyway as a result a 6 to
3 majority led by and Justice Kagan
concluded that the prohibition against
the registration of immoral or
scandalous trademarks violates the First
Amendment the majority ruled that the
Lanham Act bars were substantially over
broad
as Justice Kagan noted there are a great
many immoral and scandalous ideas in the
world even more than there are swear
words and the Lanham Act should cover
them all it therefore violates the First
Amendment to deny trademark protection
to those kind of marks the court made a
similar ruling in 2017 when it ruled
that a band named thus Lance had a right
to trademark its name the band used the
term as a way to reclaim a word that is
often used as a slur against Asians that
case wound up protecting the Washington
Redskins after the USPTO canceled the
team's trademarks after complaints that
the word Redskins was a racial slur
against Native Americans and while
reasonable people can disagree as to
whether the term Redskins is offensive
or not we can all agree that we should
fire Dan Snyder hashtag fire Dan Snyder
hashtag higher David Chang but back to
the case at hand
justices Roberts Breyer and Sotomayor
dissented although they agreed that the
word immoral is over broad they thought
the ban on scandalous trademarks is
constitutional but just needs to be more
narrowly tailored the upshot of this
decision is that it's going to open the
door to all sorts of new and interesting
and profane trademarks including many
that probably involve profanity in the
future so racist jury selection the
court handed a big win to advocates of
unbiased jury trials by ordering a new
trial for the death row inmate Curtis
flowers who has been tried six times
over the past two decades in the
American justice system of jury trials
both sides get an opportunity to strike
a limited number of jurors for cause
such as conflicts of interest the
parties also get to strike a certain
number of jurors for any reason
whatsoever these are what are known as
peremptory challenges there is one huge
caveat though the attorneys cannot use
their peremptory strikes for racial
reasons to prevent potential jurors from
being selected because of their race
this is called a Batson challenge which
we've talked about on this channel
before it goes back to the Supreme Court
case of Batson versus Mississippi in the
flowers case district attorney Doug
Evans allegedly used peremptory strikes
to dismiss black jurors from a jury pool
in all six of flowers trials Evans
eliminated 41 out of 42 black jurors the
72 majority opinion written by Justice
Kavanagh
included that the state's pattern of
striking prospective black jurors
persisted from flowers first trial
through his sixth and this was a
relentless effort to stop the jury from
having any black jurors which strongly
indicated that Evans was trying to try
flowers before the widest jury he could
possibly find and create the majority
noted that the prosecutors questioned
the black and white prospective jurors
differently for example they gave a
hundred and forty five questions to just
five perspective black jurors they asked
only twelve questions to the eleven
white jurors seated for flowers most
recent trial the prosecutor and his team
struck at least one black prospective
juror who was similarly situated to
white prospective jurors who were not
struck by the state so the flowers case
extends the doctrine that was created in
Batson versus Mississippi that you
cannot use your peremptory strikes to
strike all or most of the black jurors
from a prospective jury pool which is
exactly what happened in the John
Grisham book and movie a time to kill
I'll put a link down to my review in the
description the hotly debated census
citizenship case the US Constitution
requires the u.s. to conduct a census
every ten years this is incredibly
important for political districting
purposes the census counts every person
in the county and is used to appropriate
federal funds draw electoral districts
and apportion representatives to the
various states in March of 2018
Secretary of Commerce Wilbur Ross added
a question to the 2020 census which
required each person to state whether
they are a US citizen or not Ross
claimed that the Trump administration
added the question because it was keen
to enforce federal voting rights laws to
better protect minority voting rights
this rationale seemed pretty suspect
from the start since the Trump
administration has never filed a lawsuit
to enforce the Voting Rights Act and
that rationale ran contrary to a lot of
the actual language coming out of the
Trump administration and from President
Trump himself the outcome of this case
turned on whether the Voting Rights Act
was really the government's motive for
asking the citizenship question or not
because generally the courts don't
dispute the rationale that the
government puts forward but under the
Administrative Procedure Act any
agency action that is quote arbitrary or
capricious violates the law moreover at
a minimum an agency must disclose the
basis of its action so courts can review
its legality several states sued the
Commerce Department and argued that the
question was arbitrary and capricious
and it was a move designed solely to
isolate and marginalize people of color
particularly Latinos who may be
undocumented which would under count the
population in many US states
particularly in the southwest the
plaintiffs feared that the question
would deter many Latinos from answering
the census question because they would
fear deportation the government argued
it was simply a return to form because
from 1820 to 1950 the census included a
citizenship question the government also
questioned whether anyone had actual
standing to sue over the question and
said that the notion that people would
not answer the question truthfully was
based on sheer speculation because the
question hadn't been issued yet the
plaintiffs contended that according to
the government's own records the
citizenship question would lead to an
undercount of at least five million
people this was the government's
conclusion after the 1950 census which
is why the government dropped the
question in the first place
the plaintiffs prevailed in the lower
courts which ruled that Ross's actions
were arbitrary capricious based on
pretext and violated parts of the census
Act the district court concluded that
Ross had exceeded his authority in
crafting the question because of its
illegality the Commerce Department
appealed to the Supreme Court now the
Supreme Court narrowly sided with the
plaintiffs in a five-to-four decision
with Chief Justice casting the swing
vote the court first overruled portions
of the lower court decision the majority
of justices found that secretary Ross
had the authority to draft the census
question and was within his right as
agency head to seek records and data
however Roberts concluded that the
rationale Ross gave for the question
wanting to help minorities exercise
their voting rights was quote contrived
although agencies have broad authority
to regulate they must offer genuine
reasons for the decisions that they make
secretary Ross's reason for seeking the
data that he wanted to improve voting
rights access appeared to play no actual
role in his decision in fact Ross first
inquired about reinstating the
citizenship question just one week after
his
appointment according to Justice Roberts
altogether the evidence tells a story
that does not match the Secretary's
explanation for his decision in other
words Ross's reason for asking the
question was pretextual the court ruled
that for now the question could not go
forward
however the opinion leaves the door open
for the government to bring back the
question if they can come up with
another justification for seeking that
information in the census which takes us
to a similar case with a different
outcome that on partisan gerrymandering
partisan gerrymandering is when one
political party draws the district maps
at the other party's expense making it
easier for the party in power to stay in
power the states use census data to draw
up new maps portioning representatives
to state legislators and federal
districts for many years the political
party with the most power in the states
have drawn districts into strange shapes
that make it easier for incumbents to
hold on to power
so can state officials ever go so far in
drawing partisan districts that it
violates the US Constitution that was
the question before the Supreme Court in
this most recent case Justice Kennedy
was the swing vote back in 2004 when the
Supreme Court's conservative justices +
Kennedy whether you consider him
conservative or not ruled that the
Supreme Court should stay out of a
contentious gerrymandering case from
Pennsylvania
however Kennedy left the door ajar
stating that in a future case it could
be possible for one party to skew maps
so much that it was unconstitutional the
problem that Kennedy identified was that
there seemed to be no workable standard
for determining when gerrymandering was
unconstitutional however with Kennedy's
swing vote gone the courts conservatives
easily prevailed in the two cases
involving partisan gerrymandering in
North Carolina in Maryland during this
term in a five-to-four decision written
by Chief Justice Roberts the Supreme
Court said that the federal courts now
lacked jurisdiction to even hear
partisan gerrymandering cases Roberts
declared partisan gerrymandering as
quote nothing new and a traditional part
of partisan politics Roberts and the
other four conservative justices ruled
that the case was not just disabled and
that it runs afoul of the political
question doctrine by the way background
when a case presents a quote political
question federal courts will refuse to
hear the case the legal doctrine was
developed to prevent federal courts from
intervening in disputes that are so
politically charged that the courts feel
that they should just
out of them and let the legislators deal
with those particular questions here at
the majority held that partisan
gerrymandering claims present political
questions beyond the reach of the
federal courts which brings us to the
court's opinion in gamble versus the
United States dealing with the dual
sovereignty doctrine the dual
sovereignty doctrine is a pretty arcane
piece of jurisprudence but it generated
lots of attention because the media
covered it as if it posed the following
question could a person connected to
Donald Trump like convicted felon Paul
Manafort receive a pardon for federal
charges but still be prosecuted in the
state court for the same things however
the case pending before the court did
not involve Manta Ford or any Trump
related official but it might have
implications in to those individuals
there's a legal doctrine which holds
that because the federal and state
governments are quote separate
sovereigns the Double Jeopardy Clause
does not apply to prosecution of the
same crime under both federal and state
laws this is known as the separate
sovereigns doctrine so the question is
can a person wind up facing state and
federal prosecutions for the same
conduct or does that violate the Double
Jeopardy Clause of the Fifth Amendment
in the case at hand
Terence Gamble was convicted under
Alabama state criminal law for being a
felon in possession of a gun
he was also prosecuted under a federal
criminal law for being a felon in
possession of a gun as well he appealed
his federal conviction citing the Double
Jeopardy Clause gamble lost his appeal
in the lower courts and the Supreme
Court considered the case the Supreme
Court seven to two majority decision
affirmed that double jeopardy did not
bar Gamble's conviction
Justice Alito wrote the majority opinion
that there was no reason to overturn the
dual sovereignty doctrine the Double
Jeopardy Clause bars successive
prosecutions for the same offense not
for the same conduct that means that
gamble could not be tried twice for the
same violation of the Alabama criminal
codes but he could be tried again for
arguably the same underlying conduct in
both federal and state courts so while
the majority opinion certainly will do
nothing to advance the cause of criminal
justice reform and most defendants to be
tried by the federal government and the
state government will probably just be
regular Joe's like Terrence gamble it
does mean that any person Trump pardons
for a federal
can still be tried in state court
unconscious and emergency searches and
seizures
another Criminal Justice case from this
term placed some additional limits on
your rights under the Fourth Amendment
six years ago police found Gerald
Mitchell soaking wet and sloppy drunk in
a sandy beach in Wisconsin he was
shirtless and slurring his words
he took a preliminary breath test which
indicated his blood-alcohol level was
three times the legal limit since this
test was ineligible to be used in court
police had to decide how to get
admissible evidence of Mitchell's
condition they took him to a hospital
for a blood test there was just one
hitch Mitchell passed out in the
backseat of the squad car on the way to
the hospital
but the hospital staff drew his blood
while he was knocked out which indicated
in a blood alcohol level of 0.2 to 2 the
police never obtained a warrant
Mitchell tried to get the results of the
blood test thrown out arguing that the
cops needed a warrant but Wisconsin
state law says the drivers on his Road
presumably consent to a blood test the
Supreme Court justices ruled five to
four that the Fourth Amendment generally
does not stop states from taking a blood
sample without a warrant if the suspect
is unconscious the Fourth Amendment to
the Constitution protects your right to
unreasonable searches and seizures and
it's safe set both the right of the
people to be secure in their persons
houses papers and effects against
unreasonable searches and seizures shall
not be violated and no warrants shall
issue but upon probable cause while the
general rule is that police need a
warrant there are many exceptions to
this rule one of the exceptions is
called the exigent circumstances
exception which lets police search
without a warrant to prevent the
imminent destruction of evidence
evidence of a person's blood alcohol
level disappears over time as it is
absorbed through the bloodstream the
Supreme Court said that if police waited
until an unconscious person is awake
than the evidence that they were
intoxicated could be destroyed which
allows police to now draw blood from you
if you are unconscious without a warrant
the Bladensburg piece cross the blames
berg piece cross is a nearly century-old
monument in Maryland to those who died
in World War
the cross sits on a traffic island that
is public land in Bladensburg Maryland
the cross is associated with the
Christianity obviously so the American
Humanist Association filed a lawsuit
alleging that the crosses presence on
public land violated the First
Amendment's Establishment Clause the
courts religion cases have recently
given the government wide latitude to
include religious references on state
property and material as long as they
can be branded as quote ceremonial or
celebratory or commemorative for example
the court has ruled that the words In
God We Trust should remain on the US
currency over the objection of non
theists the court reasoned that the
message is of historical importance and
is now merely ceremonial rather than
religious the same is true of the
statement one nation under God another
Christian reference that the court says
does not run afoul of the Establishment
Clause Alito wrote a government that
roams the land tearing down monuments
with religious symbolism and scrubbing
away any reference to the divine will
strike many as aggressively hostile to
religion justices Ginsburg and Sotomayor
dissented Ginsberg wrote just as the
Star of David is not suitable to honor
Christians who died serving their
country so a cross is not suitable to
honor those of other faiths who died
defending their nation the court appears
to be drawing a line between symbols and
monuments which have been in place for
many years and those which may be
erected in the future Alito's argument
probably gave a little bit of life to
people who are angry about the removal
of old monuments however commentators
are split on what that means for new
monuments now if you're ever going to
try a case before the Supreme Court
you'll need to get a great-looking suit
as evidenced by this footage from inside
the Supreme Court all the lawyers are
dressed to the nines I'm just kidding
the Supreme Court does not allow video
recording and a lawyers generally
dressed in suits that are four sizes too
big for them still I would recommend
getting a slim cut fully custom suit
from Indo Chino and og no all of my
suits are now custom made by Indochina
including this three-piece suit that I'm
wearing right now with a custom
double-breasted vest which i think is
awesome
I know Chino will make you a fully
custom suit tailored specifically to you
for less than four hundred dollars and
the best part is they still use the best
materials like super 140 wool and
cashmere in fact I reached out to Indo
Chino to ask them to guarantee that
legal eagles would get the best price
and they were happy to oblige and I am
happy to report that legally
get the exclusive ability to buy any
premium Indo Chino suit which is their
most popular suit for 359 that is the
best deal you will find anywhere on the
Internet personally I will never buy an
off-the-rack suit again you have tons of
choices too because the secret to a
great suit is all about the fit I'm a
reasonably athletic guy and I can never
buy suits off the rack because they just
simply never fit right but with Indo
Chino you can either send your
measurements in online or you can go to
a physical store and have a stylist and
Indo Chino take your own measurements
which is what I did when I had a stylist
worked with me for over 90 minutes to
take every measurement possible we added
my measurements into the system and a
couple of weeks later I got the best
fitting suit of my entire life it was
perfect
right out of the box legal eagles can
get any premium Indo Chino suit for just
359 when you enter the code legal eagle
at checkout or use the link in the
description clicking on the link really
helps out this channel as indochina comm
promo code legal eagle for the best
custom suit of your entire life so do
you agree with my Supreme Court
summaries leave your objections in the
comments and check out my other real law
reviews over here where we tackle all of
the important legal issues of the day
click on that playlist and I will see
you in court